we see Saudi Arabia as the country of
oil and strict Islam where women wear
wheels and kisses are edited out from
films but suddenly there was a new Crown
Prince he says he wants to reform the
country women get more rights and
tourists will soon be welcome
the country has become less dependent on
oil
same time the people are ruled with an
iron fist
one wrong word can have serious
consequences in this year of changes I
travel around the country and follow the
developments on the inside Through The
Eyes of the citizens are they just empty
promises or is Saudi Arabia really able
to change
[Music]
made in Salah
foreign
[Music]
for years Saudi Arabia kept kept
Treasures hidden but with oil revenues
decreasing Crown Prince bin Salman is
looking for new sources of income
who wants to open the country up to
tourism I am taking a sneak preview
[Music]
Mont
[Applause]
foreign
Island
is it uh
out Arabic it Takens
and that Islam
this place is cursed according to
tradition Allah wanted to punish the
tamudi the original inhabitants for
their barbaric ways as they had killed a
camel mother the area was ravaged by
earthquakes and lightning Strokes
Muslims aren't allowed to visit this
place according to the Hadith and in the
statletes
[Music]
foreign
the Saudi government wants people to
forget the curse and visit the site the
green light will need to be given by
Crown Prince bin Salman luxury is tense
have already been set up and I am the
only guest sleeping here
okay
McLaughlin
[Music]
these changes are driven by the
country's young people seventy percent
of the population is less than 30 years
old
this demographic group increasingly
doesn't want to be told what to do
[Music]
a little a little uh goodbye
Jambu writers group
my fish smell capules my fish no no it's
harder tomorrow
hurry up menu
foreign
[Music]
guys are taking a big risk talking about
this out on the streets we are
accompanied by a man from the ministry
of media
he takes pictures for his report the
government keeps a check on everything
[Music]
the guys disappear in traffic again
they remain anonymous they didn't give
their names
Saudi Arabia's new strong man Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman says he feels
connected to young people
MBS as he's called says he wants to
embark on a new course
the feared religious police that checks
whether Islamic laws are respected is
restrained and women get more rights
[Music]
in Jeddah the gateway to Saudi Arabia
the fight for reforms has been fought
for years below the surface
is one of its fiercest Warriors
she wants to receive official permission
for guiding visitors so this is a
characteristics in all the historical
cities
okay let's go from here
if your guest is not interested you stop
you move to the next movement
my father was at the sheikhil Tyrrell so
we had to move with him since the age of
nine years old so I love traveling I
love tourism and this is what made me
start as a tour guide
now I have been working seven years
in a new job it was at that time a lot
of women tourists guys uh well I was the
only one wow the only one yes you
started yes as a female
did you get any negative reactions
only negative reaction that I had was
from The Men tour guide
they didn't like this
these men they will go and try to
complain because I was not certified the
certificate is only for men
as a woman you can't get a certificate
of a tour guide
some of them went to the police station
and what happened with the complaints
when they saw my case they were laughing
there is no killing there is a no
injuries what is this so I explained
they said just continue but try to bring
a permission from a higher rank and this
is what happened hopefully in a few
months I'm going to get my license
official after eight years officially
what characterized the city of Jeddah
look up Roshan yes what is the Roshan
Russia it's a Persian word means like
window well a beer awaits official
permission she tries to train the Next
Generation young guys who received
permission from the parents to guide
foreigners
you will take the role of explains
we can notice here few things the first
thing is that the houses are so close to
each other and they also used to name
them as houses they don't say a building
or such and what makes the house unique
is also their doors or their Gates see
every single door of every single house
is unique and you cannot find two
identical doors okay this is my gosh
oh
and you see the ventilation that is
failure trousers appear in it in the
middle of the
uncertain Street fire sign you look at
their face
of the air forming is
[Music]
what do you study I study English and
translation I can imagine it's not easy
for a girl to be a yes tourist guide
maybe for some families well yes it's
because there are a lot of men around us
and that's kind of creeps them out a bit
is it the man who gives negative
reactions well yes sometimes it's men
other times it's women but mostly men
when they see you doing a good thing
better than them they'll be like why
would you do that why is she better than
us so I uh we faced many issues because
we're women here working when the women
start driving there'll be a lot of
problems from well problems you know
um men might be aggressive sometimes
if you ever notice on Twitter some
people talk that they will burn the cars
of women that they will hit the woman
that they will harass her and stuff
really yes they do that a lot but what
is their problem it's kind of hard to to
get the picture of us a woman working
and there are a lot of guys listening to
us it's very brave uh I love it so yeah
the new freedoms for women have been
dictated by the Crown Prince
women who profit from it like pharah and
Abeer feel strengthened by it but Amir
is it not better that change comes from
the button than from above and put its
own people do I have to wait centuries
to have the right to drive do we have to
wait centuries to have the right not to
have a guardian so as long as we have
these small groups who are disturbing
our development no it must come from up
this is the only way to let everybody
accept their
changes
a lot of resistance needs to be overcome
from clergymen the government the
conservative part of the population
steps are being made
but if you want to survive it's crucial
that you know how far you can go
Malik Niger teaches me how to recognize
these limits
it provokes the authorities every day
and has become hugely popular we made a
show named masamir it's distributed
online we've surpassed 750 million views
750 million Millions views wow in all
Middle East yeah how is that possible
such a big success
there's basically we go to places where
other people don't dare to go
I think there is a sense of uh novelty
when you see some characters that
represents your society and I think this
is definitely this is what people see in
our creations
so the cartoons are from the real life
of Saudi Arabia from real people also
inspired by real people you know we talk
a lot of taboos in our society
animation allows you to go further than
what you would usually do you get more
tolerated exactly it's like a Joker
dancing around the king and making jokes
you know and the King will just tolerate
this joke because after all he's not a
serious figure
what's your favorite character I'd say
Dr Adeline this is Dr Adam yeah this is
Dr adir he's feeding his pet frog and
you know the pet frog doesn't really
like him very much for the Saudis this
is a new type of social commentary the
show exposes all kinds of problems in
society most of all Malik lets his
animated figures ridicule the government
yeah I'm gonna do Dr Adel Dr Adam okay
right and he would go something like
this
um
it is only when people are horrified
that means okay you're breaking new
grounds now that is a thin line right
because you want to create this
conflict but you don't want to overdo it
but isn't it difficult to break down
taboos it is but every time we create
something we tend to gauge
what's going on and so I've created
something about women rights issues
right I've created something that is
mocking this ridiculous idea of women
are not allowed to drive and so what we
do is basically we just
you know start piece by piece first time
we just show a woman that drives BMW
says
[Music]
so the second time she turns him into a
car you know she's driving him right
right this is driving on his back
and I remember when you put that
we got a lot of negative feedback is
that a red line it used to be it used to
be I mean I was there right five years
ago it was a red line yeah you know you
know people will get furious about that
foreign
[Music]
ignores all the comments she gets when
she's not wearing any cup
or goes out without a guardian
she is willing to give me a peek into
her life
we meet somewhere so that I can give her
her first driving lessons
it's easy
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
you have acceleration and you have the
brake
take it very slow from the break now
oh
that's good
yes like this
very good
[Music]
be careful
break break break
slowly break yes very good okay
how does it feel driving feels good yeah
it feels good
is it special for you
I think it is yes first time driving
nobody says no
out of ten how good am I you are
fantastic thank you
did your mom ever drive
no she never did I actually she's not a
supportive of driving no she's not no my
dad is
but she's not and why your mother
doesn't want
she's not used to this okay to the whole
idea like I said not part of the culture
or anything
so they're moving slowly
step by step it's like in our religion
it's not wrong to drive it's not wrong
to open our faces
you never had any cup
no never so it's kind of personal see
nowadays people a woman can open their
hairs they can open their faces we have
these things called the Leia they were
very active like we were walking on a
mall I remember that I was once walking
in a mall and my abide was opened down
so the guy came and he yelled at me he's
like close your Abaya
where are they now they're gone now
so what would happen if we were talking
like this three years ago here on this
Cornish oh that would be super wrong
like uh
you and I would be freaked out like
don't talk to me pretend you're doing
something there just don't talk to me
directly it would be so weird to do that
the higher the feared religious police
may have been disbanded but this doesn't
mean that pharah and I aren't being
watched
we managed to brush the attention off
for a while I am afraid she won't dare
to continue but she won't let the man
intimidate her men here some of them
have control over women like she's mine
no one can look at her she doesn't do
anything behind my back my word that
goes right and everything but there are
others that knows we're actual human we
have rights and we have uh life we
really need a life
like I can't walk behind a mine my whole
life
foreign
[Music]
would think that more women would take
the freedom of dropping the wheel now
that the higher is powerless but the
ancient Islamic regulations are still
being respected
[Music]
now there is a how to shopping malls in
Saudi Arabia
the Saudis have a healthy
foreign
[Music]
the shopping mall is slowly emptying out
these men are also going to pray they
still support the work of the higher
one of them is willing to talk but we
can't speak freely in the shopping mall
we are being watched too closely for
that
he would rather receive me on his own
territory
I'm invited to visit him outside of the
city
oh well oh oh well
[Music]
uh
foreign
[Music]
oh hello
good oh milk
oh very good good fresh fresh
[Laughter]
outside of the Cities conservatism still
rules Supreme
many supporters of alhaya can be found
here for Walid the organization is also
of the highest importance
of
um
Jamila
well it fanatically clings to the
demands al-haya puts on women such as
the mandatory wearing of the Abaya
foreign
gliding
like more best intimidation and it come
out for us
the walls in this country are almost
impenetrable
conservatism on one side more freedoms
on the other cafes and restaurants have
separate rooms for men and women there
are exceptions and I meet pharah in one
of them she finds it difficult to escape
from these Traditions she's open about
that
and I was asked how's Ash well I got
engaged uh but it was arranged uh
arranged marriage by my parents how did
it start
the guy who got uh proposed for me was
from our family I kind of had this hard
pressure on me to say yes and I said I
said yes I did we got engaged for uh
three to four months and then uh things
turned out to be
very uh like how can I say that first he
didn't want me to work as a tour guide
and uh he preferred me working in a
female area only
um I didn't agree to that so he didn't
want you to work as the two guys yeah
and that's that's your dream yeah you
just told me just leave it on your mind
that I don't want you to do that so
he didn't just say no and refused at the
first place but
you never know
she managed to get out of the arranged
marriage
the first to show tourists around the
only question is how she will now meet
her future partner how do girls and boys
meet each other so work
um
relatives you know or a friend not
spontaneously
just in the cafe like this well if it
happens spontaneously like you mean I
would get up and say or that guy would
get up and come sit with me yeah or just
that you have a date here
uh that's pretty odd I don't know never
happened to me so I don't know
it would be weird if a guy came and said
can I grab a cup of coffee with you
it'll be weird to know what you want
stay away from me
in the west there is a lot of places
where you can meet someone well there
are like mixed parties that were not a
lot to do but it happens anyway
foreign
but come on you don't go I don't like it
please come it's a gym setlist with the
black van
first they'll take all the whole girls
and guys call their parents
and then send them home
young Saudis have their own rituals with
which they provoke the police
they look for ways to get into touch
with each other
[Music]
plans
[Applause]
[Music]
why the guys were running
police police yeah but why they are
running for police
did he talk to a girl what did he do we
were just walking yeah and they catch it
but what happens when the police catches
you you go to the bus and then they get
you to a small prison a small prison yes
[Applause]
you also chasing girls oh yes yes
without the police yes
[Music]
[Applause]
Allah
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
bikini
this is
foreign
[Music]
he has come up with a special plan to
spread the Islamic faith
extra power
ful yes
[Music]
this is
foreign
and at the entity government
um
[Music]
foreign
wants the entire world to become Muslim
right after I have left Walid puts
comments on our meeting online
I see that he has over 1 million
followers
[Applause]
this is the conservatism that is
blocking new freedoms
anybody who opposes it will be resisted
which thing was where you get most
negative reactions about
yeah there was an episode
that we created
these guys who basically these three
guys who decided to be
you know we have the Haya here in Saudi
Arabia which is the uh religious police
religious police I mean pretty recently
they started losing their grip on
society right we created this episode
where these three people who do the same
thing but in a reverse way they go out
find people who are not happy who are
not enjoying life and making sure they
enjoy so you can see this guy he's
obviously a religious figure and then
there's this guy on the other side here
he's liberal he calls the police and he
tells them I see a guy who doesn't look
happy you guys need to come over here
and sort it out immediately
This Is How They always come yeah
and there's a logo
why aren't you smiling
and this guy has a good reason not to
smile because he had a bad day and then
they just said okay guys take him in
color
there's a reverse of what happened yeah
exactly this is a reversal of what
happens
what is animations Malik helped erode
the authority of the religious police
but where is the limit
to survive in this country it is crucial
that you know how far you can go you're
walking in a Minefield right and and so
that's how it is this is how the game is
played it's religion a red line
um it depends on what is it yeah but can
you make fun of the Royal Family
you can't you can't make funny things
about the Royal house so that's the red
line that is a red line yeah this might
put us into trouble so I'm also walking
in a Minefield as a journalist
well you are but by the time this will
be published you'll be it'll be
somewhere safe
Malik's fair is Justified a few weeks
later there is an example of why pushing
the limits is dangerous just before the
prohibition on women driving is canceled
a couple of activists who fought for
that are arrested they are accused of
Espionage and treason
it causes a lot of confusion what is the
direction of the reforms
and
it could be a vehicle where
um
foreign
it is under these circumstances that I
meet pharah again
I am tense I am curious how she holds
out the mood in the country has changed
so much that it isn't clear how far we
can go during our conversation
have a seat
this is a very exciting place here it's
really nice atmosphere here well you
don't see the separation between men and
female here so that's another advantage
of the place I think you know is this
the new Saudi Arabia fire or is it just
a free place
oh god
well let's just call it a free place we
don't know how Saudi Arabia is gonna be
a signals without hijab do you also come
without hijab to this gift oh no no
what I was brought up so so you're not
going to take it off no oh also not in
the future well you don't know
people change beliefs change with time
so you never know
Farah hopes that the changes will be
carried through and that you will have
the same opportunities as the man around
her
do you have your license no not yet it's
too expensive boy why it's expensive
well comparing it to guys license it's
about 2 000 to 3 000 for us females and
for guys it's 400 reals so women pay
more than men it's really unfair but I
think they want to you know like good
drivers go out to the world not not just
anyone
so the thing is that you know what's
going on in Saudi Arabia before we could
talk about anything but now there is the
um
something criminal you know if you said
something that against the
the will of the country you'll get you
get problems yes you get a lot of
problems caught between tradition and
modernization Farah tries to find her
way
she has tasted freedom for a short while
until the royal family intervened
it's clear that openness in Saudi Arabia
has its limits
[Music]
foreign
the pride of Saudi Arabia is the Arabian
horse
it is fast Nimble and it has a lot of
stamina
Saudis admire this animal to no end
that's happened here
fantasies
foreign
[Laughter]
very nice
of a um
foreign
[Music]
this horse has always been linked to the
country's rich and Powerful
many of them have their own Thoroughbred
Arabian horse
every year they gather at the largest
horse festival in eastern Saudi Arabia
this is a party
for the elite
[Music]
this way
you could say nobody
better understand
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
security has taken up a few notches
awaiting the arrival of Prince bin naive
he was once regarded as the Crown Prince
he wants to win and if he doesn't he
will simply buy the horse that won
ladies and gentlemen we are about to
announce
[Music]
a very very exciting and interesting
competition they were all about the
90-point marker
no one knows how many princes there are
exactly it is estimated that there are
several thousands
[Music]
the house of Saud Reigns Supreme
many of the most important jobs are
assigned to family members
Prince been naive is governor of the
Eastern province
safety
that is the steepest house
questions are not allowed the Royal
Family's worth is law in this country
they have a firm grip on the most
important source of income
oil
[Music]
gigantic amount of it
had been found by Western geologists
under the Arabian peninsulas desert
Plains
and an exiting an aramco auto
can we go closer of course please this
is the first oil well in the Kingdom
Saudi Arabia the first place where they
found oil correct this is the really
first place yes correct yeah they
actually started by drawing 10 Wells at
that time 1933. so they told world
number one number two three for number
one they find just gas and some water
and number two no oil they were totally
disappointed
unlike their neighboring countries the
disappointed Saudis didn't find any oil
but a stubborn American geologist called
Mark steineke kept searching his idea
was to drill deeper
[Music]
so max he decided just randomly to come
back to rule number seven and then he
drove
he drove to like
1441 meters wow then the oil started to
struck so the history could be different
for us if we were the one who found the
oil but it was the Americans it was the
Americans and that's where we had the
Constitutional agreement with the
American geologists and that's where
they named the aramco company aramco
which came from Arabian American Oil
Company since they are the one who
discovered the oil so it was like 50
investment and now no now it's been uh
Saudi totally Saudi totally Saudi and
where does the revenue of aramco go it's
government-owned country company also to
the Royal House
yes of course because it's government
and
correct
I see that Alina is taking a back she
just admitted that a lot of the oil
revenues flow to the Royal Family
how much is a secret aramco is the most
profitable company in the world it is
worth almost two trillion dollars
the oil Discovery also meant that more
westerners entered the country
they took up residence behind the closed
doors of aramco together with Saudi
employees
how long do you work for aramco for
aramco now 20 years on the compound I
used to but I moved out yes I used to I
like it there because it's more
convenient for me I have my car I'm
driving moving around so that was a good
thing so you're driving a car on the
compound oh yes and outside the compound
no
so the life inside the compound is
different as outside the compound
absolutely we call it the Little America
because we have all the facilities even
the greens the plants the gardens the
houses are built like in American style
so women can drive so it's absolutely
Little America but to be honest I
traveled in Saudi Arabia now for weeks
you're the first one first female that
tells me that she's working for 20 years
because it was an Arabian American Oil
Company and at that time we hired so
many Americans a large number of
Americans
females and males of course so and that
is the big influence so aramco had it
had a role in the emancipation of Saudi
women yes yes yes of course and we're
proud of that
Alina is quite Frank and so she's no
longer allowed to guide us for years a
wheel of secrecy has hung over the
compound
many Saudis considered this place to be
depraved men and women mingled freely
here
the strictly Islamic Society took
offense at this
we have to hide our camera
[Music]
here
foreign
the Americans were involved with the oil
extraction
this enabled the countries to strike a
wonderful deal when they needed each
other most
a Bitter Lake Worth
President Roosevelt and the Saudis
accounting abdulaziz
and the offering comes that is
after 1945 America needed lots of oil
Saudi Arabia was able to deliver it and
the country's founder King abdulaziz saw
it as an opportunity to spread his fate
the Saudis agreed to exchange oil for
money but they would decide how it was
spent
assistant
[Music]
it's the annual classic car show we do
every year it's a gathering for people
to enjoy the car to enjoy the beautiful
designs of the 50s and 40s classicals
and the Saudis like cars yeah they love
cars we used to buy pickups so we can
carry stuff uh ships camels and people
in the pickup
because you didn't find oil yet then
yeah no the oil was found in Saudi
Arabia from the 30s but it was not uh as
much as today so thanks God for all what
we have alhamdulillah
the discovery of oil led to an abundant
supply of money and most of it ended up
here indria a town near Riyadh
ever since the founding of Saudi Arabia
this is where power and Faith converge
I heard that also some cars are from the
royal family yeah that's true yes uh
King Salman to support the youth and the
show he accept to present four of his
personal car
that he used to drive in the 70s
is it possible to buy a car from a royal
family it's possible but it's rare so
it's expensive
so this is for the rich saudiers depends
how do you find Rich
maybe you say if you have one million
you are rich but for me maybe a hundred
million dollar is a rich guy what is
Rich for you 100 million
[Music]
galaxies
we are lucky
the organizer of the auto show sees one
of the truly wealthy walk by Prince
South bin turkey alsawood you're from
the royal family yeah so are you gonna
buy a car at the auction maybe maybe
which one the red one the red one yeah
yeah he likes the red one he's Rich how
many princes there are in Saudi Arabia
maybe four or three five thousand four
or three five thousand wow that's a
that's a lot of friends isn't it yeah
you know them all also yes I know
everybody not uh in particular but I
know them home
can I ask you another question yeah in
the family uh you are also speaking
about the changes how how is that in the
inside the family uh everybody's happy
about it yeah yeah everybody supports
also we support 200 everything you can
excuse me
the prince is extremely friendly but as
soon as we talk about the reforms he has
to go
and he doesn't want to talk to me later
on either
I feel that we need to be careful
King Salman's car hasn't been solved his
Palace is nearby
fortunately satam allows me to get in
he's willing to bring me closer he knows
the town inside out
foreign
so we are royal now with the red carpet
we are famous
I'm from today
my grandfather is from Drea
and also I'm with the prince of Drea as
a close friend
we see King Salman's Country House rise
up in the distance
one of the locals I met at the auto show
is willing to bring me closer to the
Palace
only later do I find out how powerful is
King Salman
he's there now King Salman yeah
for Saudi Arabia
it's huge big Kabir hey no
no no
um
it it relies from the out conning from
the ears to coning suit and on the side
from the stud this is
so this is the most important city in
Saudi Arabia then
uh
foreign
not only is this small City the
birthplace of the House of Saud but it
is also here that in the 18th century
the alliance was forged between Muhammad
even Saud and religious leader Sheikh
Abdul Al wahab
this Alliance found massive support and
led to the Saudi Arabia of today the
Royal House of Saud Rose to power thanks
to wahhabism
the ultra Orthodox Islamic Doctrine as
state religion
so that was the Palace of King South but
what about al-wahab
ad was
hello
to my surprise we are right next to the
mosque
Mansoor is the head of an important
family in the Ria
without asking permission he takes me to
the mosque of Abdul al-wahab
the religious reformer who introduced
wahhabism three centuries ago
he said that those who didn't follow the
true Faith could even be fought with
violence
foreign these ideas inspired groups like
Al-Qaeda and Isis to spread death and
destruction
sir there are some groups who are using
his ideology to to use violence they
call him an extremist what do you think
about that turkey
my visit to the mosque reveals a sore
spot
the ideology that has been exported
using oil money leading to violence in
other places has its Origins here
Mansoor wants to rectify this image
okay
this is foreign
the proving fundamentalism that was
embraced by many Saudis first damaged
the house of Saud itself
as a protest against foreign influences
and women's rights such as aramco's
Little America the unfathomable happens
Mecca the Saudi holy place is attacked
by a handful of extremists in 1979
um
a travel to Jeddah to talk to an
editor-in-chief who saw it happen up
close and isn't afraid to talk about it
[Music]
it was a game changer
there was a creeping tide of extremism
had come but how did it change because
how was it before and how was it after
we were normal people and I saw all the
James Bond movies in Saudi Arabia
injured they're with my mother in the
70s and early 80s it was totally
different before the Sahara came The
Awakening came
foreign
rested on the alliance with religious
leaders
but resistance had grown the attackers
were executed and he had a solution to
prevent further uprisings why bism
needed to be followed more strictly this
was called The Awakening so this sahore
The Awakening that came in 30 years was
really disastrous for there and then the
attack came and then everything changed
yes and what was the first thing but
changed I mean the relegation of women
in the background the mosques used to
come and say things around things that
were totally alien I mean things that
didn't even concern us covering the
faces held fire Brimstone Born Again
Muslims the bad thing on that attack is
that the aggressor won he wanted
something that the country gets more
conservative yes and he succeed in that
so he lost the battle but when the war
it brought in dark clouds I think it was
high hijacked by preachers
from then on religious conservatism had
an even tighter grip on Saudi Arabia
women were forced to cover their faces
Cinemas were closed while the doors
opened for extremism
we have supported many organizations
here and there and there of course there
are issue the issue of extremism the
attack on the Haram the the rising tide
of intolerance yes we admit we made a
mistake and then even the Quran Prince
said that we made a mistake and that
caused all these problems
the extremism reached its apogee during
the September 11 attacks
not far from the editor-in-chief's
office is the birthplace of the man who
changed the world
[Music]
[Applause]
is this official yeah yeah this is the
leather route
foreign
's father made his money constructing
roads he was closely tied to the Saudi
royal family
after oil was discovered he was assigned
large construction projects
we aren't allowed to film here either
days
[Music]
let me walk here walk walk
stop here yeah
this mosque contributed to his
radicalization and is closed now but the
effect of the sermons here has changed
the way the World Views Saudi Arabia
forever
now that the country appears to be
opening up I am invited by Mansoor and
his son Salah to visit their home they
want to distance themselves from the
extremism
of course we had all the attacks
and all the all the world they don't
know of course they will link the
terrorism with us which is wrong but
there is a strict form of the Islam in
Saudi Arabia you agree on that we had
some conservative
periods but that doesn't mean that we
accept the terrorism or the jihadis or
any any part of those uh of that
ideology but 911 it made a very bad
image of Saudi Arabia of course that
affect us and the first people who got
hurt are us and that the attacks of them
in Saudi Arabia and we left it and we
were scared out of it and we hated it
was in Saudi Arabia more than 60 or 70
attack in Saudi Arabia and it was Bloody
ugly thing that no human can accept ever
Muhammad bin Salman slams The Door in
the face of extremism he says he wants
to return to moderate Islam of before
1979.
this makes him popular among young
people
that is
the good thing about his Royal Highness
his
um his uh we studied at the same school
by the way yeah do you know him also yes
personal When We Were Young we lived the
normal life that the the young
population lived and he heard their
needs and he was one of them now as a
leader
he he's taking us to to to what is what
is called uh future
it is Friday
family
Elite of Saudi Arabia Gathers
I am asked to stay and eat with them
the guests are surprised to see me
[Music]
who are these people is it all family no
no not all of them are family we have
like Architects Engineers generals how
important is this for the Saudi people
you find it in all the families it's
very important if anyone needs anything
from the other so they can help each
other
this is
my grandfather now he was one with the
King that King of the last season
so the family has a very close tie
they've shared the the county for a long
long time
so then I understand the Loyalty of you
and the people to the kingdom you know
that our parents our grandparents
they're passing this loyalty to us and
and we're going to carry on to my son
and so forth this is the protective ring
around the Royal Family
they are most loyal
the question is whether it is possible
to criticize the royal family like
Critics on the royal families that well
is that possible yeah hopefully openly
without getting any penalty no no I mean
critic I mean if a Critic is within the
boundaries of respect fine but you don't
go and start shouting and bluffing or
saying lies and they were letting go
and if you do if you do that if you do
that
you get penalties I mean they should be
finalized I mean if somebody was not
respecting the king or the the laws and
everything he should not be respected
you might get me in trouble now huh
clearly a fear to say something wrong
even among the elite
Salah takes me to the place where there
are women
he'd rather show me the image of the new
Saudi Arabia
this is the cape by the government
we have the entertainment Authority it's
a new Authority uh started because the
entertainment Authority yes wow yeah and
they are planning to make 5500 events in
like this
it's very crowdy here yeah it's very
crowdy and you see all the kind of the
community the old and the young girls
ladies and uh but a lot of girls yeah
they're happy to be here and to have
this opportunity with them
what happened with Saudi Arabia well we
have the great Crown Prince and he's
doing a very great job supporting the
young population so people are ready for
change yeah they are happy and he's an
idol and does the Crown Prince also work
on better human rights for Saudi Arabia
yes he's promised with a good bitter and
and he's doing very well what he did in
two years it it take another country's
100 years to change it this fast
for Salah the Crown Prince is a synonym
for change
the government supports young people
financially to start small companies
this only increases the faith and
reforms is this the new energy in Saudi
Arabia yes yeah yes because you know 70
percent of Saudi population they are
under 30 years old very young population
very young but they are all have this
energy to work and they have energy to
to produce things so nobody can stop the
changes
we will make it to go further I'm sure
is my country I can't leave it I have to
fight for it
young people are fighting for their
reforms but this is made much harder due
to events surrounding the Crown Prince
on the 2nd of October 2018
journalist Jamal khashoggi is murdered
in the Saudi consulate in Istanbul
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman is
suspected of giving the order
the royal family denies it
as the news is reported I try to go
public opinion in Saudi Arabia itself
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
for journalists in this country
it is simply safest to remain silent
Khalid
al-main's editor-in-chief for 12 years
is willing to take the risk and talks
I was looking to Saudi newspapers it was
all the same headlines with the same
picture see every newspaper depends on
its own editors there are those who want
to and there are those now today in the
Arab News Faisal Abbas or what a
beautiful article saying that um you
know after this sad incident things have
to change so I think it's important to
have real journalists people who care
more for society because journalism is
not an easy thing it is a very dangerous
job also what happened is also
acknowledgment about that there is no
press Freedom what happened with these
journalist no no it was uh I I would be
the first to tell you that it was a
total not error it was a company it was
a crime and all and the government has
accepted the fact I mean a lot of these
things happened nobody's condoning I'm
the last person because it could have
been anyone but this should never happen
again I mean this has happened
unfortunately yeah but this journalist
couldn't work in Saudi Arabia and flew
abroad
because he he said I couldn't work here
I was you know his house for 12 years
he had several issues I applaud him for
this but then he did went and only said
that he could not for fear of being
taken aside
but you agree with me that things
happenings like this it doesn't make uh
Saudi Arabia's
um image in the west not very
good it doesn't make the image look good
here yeah you you think that the people
here approved of this believe me I am
sure that the people who did this and I
pray to God that the people who did this
will be taken to task it will be made
public and there should be no stone
unturned to find out the motives of the
killers and who were the killers the
editor-in-chief carefully weighs his
words he knows about the accusations
against Muhammad bin Salman
is it possible to criticize
MBS or his policy
there's a way to do it you know there's
a way to do it I mean I have even been
writing about the sponsorship system
which I think it was and I wrote it as
slavery in
McKenna newspaper I wrote In The Gazette
and all nothing happened to me
today if there are elections he will win
hands down believe me I would vote for
him not for somebody else we don't want
somebody who's
uh archaic person we don't want somebody
to take us backwards
soji's former editor-in-chief draws a
line at the Royal Family criticism is
fine as long as it isn't directed
towards Muhammad bin Salman not just out
of fear of retaliation but also the fear
of returning to the old Saudi Arabia
the only thing left to do is to attend
this first mixed screening with Saleh he
tries to be proud of what has been
achieved so far
but he knows his beloved Crown Prince
has shown the world another side of him
next week I followed the pilgrims Trail
all the way to the holy Kaaba in Mecca
so God has given the power to Saudi
Arabia I think it is a gift from God
there is a call for moderate Islam but
do religious leaders support it
foreign
[Music]